una tragedia acaba de golpear a esta
familia la abuela de oksana murió
el silencio los inunda y luego la ira un
enojo por la impotencia ante una guerra
que tiene como objetivo a los civiles de
túnez que
se sentó en el banco y descanso
qué podemos hacer ahora ya no se puede
hacer nada cuántas personas más morirán
cuando terminara todo esto vivíamos no
tocábamos a nadie y eso era todo
trabajamos sabíamos que había un trabajo
un salario un anticipo podíamos irnos de
vacaciones como lo hacemos ahora
prepárense el siguiente está por llegar
por última vez el ente que agradeció
eeuu su ayuda adicional de 400 millones
de dólares pero el presidente pidió más
armas ante la intensificación de la
ofensiva rusa
en un solo día rusia golpeó mykolaiv
kharkiv crivi rick y otras ciudades en
la región de donges golpeó de forma
precisa y deliberada zonas residenciales
con casas normales objetos civiles
personas los sistemas adicionales de
cohetes de artillería de alta movilidad
y otras armas de precisión nos permiten
tomar medidas antiterroristas y reducir
los ataques de misiles rusos contra
nuestros ciudadanos estas acciones
terroristas sólo pueden ser detenidas
con armas modernas y potentes
los combatientes ucranianos parecen
seguir resistiendo pero hasta cuando la
conquista de la región de dónetsk se ha
convertido en la prioridad de moscú y
daría a rusia su primera victoria
significativa la de controlar toda la
región del donbass